- There's something uncanny
valley about them, right?
Like I feel like I'm in Blade Runner
and one of them is definitely not human.
(swooshing)
(metal creaking)
(light playful lounge music)
- [Green Jacket Man] I'm gonna say
I'm not hip with the teens.
I don't know what they're up to.
I seem 'em out there on Twitter,
yellin' at each other.
- Man, when I was 16,
I was a mess.
(light playful lounge music)
Oh yeah.
I don't know who that is.
- I think he's a Disney channel actor.
- That looks like a young John Mayer,
who is this?
He looks like Justin Bieber's brother.
- I'm gonna guess...
Bernard Lorfjack.
- Is this that Shawn boy?
(bell dings)
Is this a Shawn boy?
- This is like a cross
between Shawn Mendes
and that guy from Twilight.
- Wait, is that Shawn Mendes?
No, it's not!
- [Bearded Man] He sang to my baby, right?
Yeah, he looks different here.
- [Man In Tan Shirt]
Oh, I know who this is.
Uh...
- [Man With Chin Dimple]
I've seen her do something,
somewhere.
- She's at Beautycon,
so she's a makeup person.
- I was just watching something
that she made last week.
This is embarrassing.
- Beautiful,
neutral,
Liza Koshy.
(chime dings)
And she'll do like things
where she comes onto camera.
(swoosh sound)
Oh hey, what's up.
- She's a vine, I shoulda said viner!
- Liza Koshy, YouTuber.
Great transitions.
(light playful lounge music)
- It's a k-pop group.
Right?
- They're probably called something like
Totally Now.
- Buh buh bub bub ba buh buh
- They're cool lookin'.
- Okay, one of them is not looking
at the camera.
This guy right here,
what's he lookin' at?
- BTK? No he was the serial killer
(laughs awkwardly)
Woops.
- Oh, letters B, A, E.
- This is BTS.
(chime dings)
Yeah of course.
They're definitely hot boys,
I'll tell you that much.
(light playful lounge music)
- [Bearded Man] (heavy breathing)
I don't know.
- She's a singer.
She's at a Z100 event.
Using my detective skills here.
- I don't know, I have no idea.
- [Gray Hoodie Man] I know who this is.
Camilla
(chime dings)
Kabeza
(angry buzz)
Is that how you say her last name?
Yeah she left One Direction,
no hard feelings.
- Oh she's got songs.
I know her name.
I've just never seen her face.
- What's a Fifth Harmony
song I would know?
(light playful lounge music)
- [Gray Hoodie Man] I would guess
that these are DJ's.
These are Dj's from Finland.
- I'm gonna say that they're
popular on some App like Snapchat.
- Ugh who are these guys?
- Is this two different people
or the same person?
Are they twins?
- These guys are probably named
Jack and Bob,
and they probably have a chain of COD job.
- Even if I did know who they were,
I'd probably actively try to avoid
knowing too much about them,
'cause twins can kill each other
with their minds
and I'm not comfortable with that.
- Dolan twins.
Would they have been successful
had they not been twins.
I wonder the same thing
about Mary-Kate and Ashley.
- I guess I feel old.
Is that what you want me to say?
- When all else fails,
they're probably viners.
(light playful lounge music)
(playful lounge music, piano solo)
(swoosh sound)
(metal creaking)